- La Cour suprême a déterminétoe
et à perpétuité de personnes
reconnues coupables de
crimes sexuels au Registre
atteinte au droit à la liberté,
garanti par la Charte.
Dans un jugement
rendu à 5 contre 4,
les magistrats affirment que :
Le plus haut tribunal du pays
donne donc raison au plaignant,
coupable en 2015 de deux chefs
d'accusation d'agressions
sexuelles commises en 2011.
À l'époque, la juge
de première instance écrivait
de récidive de l'homme était
peu probable. Mais en vertu
de la loi, il devait néanmoins
être inscrit au Registre
des délinquants sexuels.
- Une obligation de prendre
en considération la situation
- Jean-Claude Bernheim, expert
en criminologie et défenseur
des droits des détenus,
partage l'avis du tribunal :
il est inexact de dire que
présentent un risque accru
de récidive.
JEAN-CLAUDE BERNHEIM,
- Si on veut que cette notion de
réhalilitation, de réintégration
sociale puisse être réellement
appliquée, il faut queononononon
des condamnations soit faiteà pn
individuelle de chaque personne,
je me sentirais peut-être
moins en sécurité qu'avant
que cette décision-là tombe.
- Le sénateudododododododododode
en 2002 par un délinquant sexuel
récidiviste, se demande
qui déterminera les critères
d'inscription.
- Je pense qu'il faut que
l'inscription au registre...
pour les prédateurs
récidivistes, surtout'e'e'e'e'e,
il faut que l'inscription soit
obligatoire. Je pense que ce
qu'il faut laisser maintenant
aux juges, c'est la  i i i i i ,
en enlevant la notion
de perpétuité.
- Le gouvernement a un an
pour réécrire ququququququququqe
au Registre soit invalidée.
Cependant, les inscriptions
à perpétuité au Registre
des
sont maintenant impossibles.
Dans une déclaration,
le ministre de la Justice
dit demeurer engagé à donner
tous les outils nécessaires
pour prévenir et enquêter
sur les crimes sexuels.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canad O Ottaw